the certificate program in
entrepreneurship and innovation brings
actually two wonderful arms or two
wonderful units of Stanford the School
of Engineering which of course has had
many illustrious entrepreneurs who've
tree shaped really our life and also of
course my own home school the Graduate
School of Business which has generated
many many entrepreneurs who've actually
created medical organization hedge funds
private equity you name it they're all
there so you can think of all of the
discourses if you will a giant virtual
incubator that's what the course is
about so don't think certificate think
incubator
so a good way to think about this
certificate is it mixes what we call
clean models and dirty hands well you
need clean models or social designs to
figure out how do you become an
entrepreneur how do you innovate you
also need dirty hands
so some courses are very clean models
kinds of courses so you might take a
course you know for example on how to
forecast demand you know how do you
develop for instance a marketing plan
and the other extreme you might have a
dirty hands course that tells you how do
you go about prototyping new products
you might have another dirty hands
course that says hey you might have an
idea about entrepreneurship or
innovation how do you convert that into
a story or you could actually have a
dirty hands course and how do you
negotiate better but then you could have
clean models courses on can we develop
business models and endow them with the
agility can we actually think of
strategy in the context of information
technology so what we've tried to do is
give people models to actually
understand maps if you will to
understand the world but also
experiences
so relevant offering for anybody who is
interested in making things better and
anybody interested in taking a little
bit of risk
there may be a number of other places
that study entrepreneurship and
innovation but through sheer
circumstance of location we are located
of course in Silicon Valley you know
being here you sort of breathe the air
it's hard not to think about
entrepreneurship and innovation when
your students are thinking about new
ventures in the first five six months
after join the MBA program or the
engineering program everybody is
thinking innovation everybody's thinking
entrepreneurship so this is a place so
that breeds all of this and because the
air is full of all of this we think we
actually have how shall I put it very
cutting-edge practices cutting-edge
ideas that may take a little bit of time
to travel to the rest of the world
we've thought long and hard about user
experience we've thought very carefully
about the material we've you know
brought into the program so you will
notice that the online courses have been
carefully designed in short increments
of lectures punctuated with specially
designed assignments it's cutting edge
material material that carefully thinks
of the user I would say the other part
is it's not it would be a gross
oversimplification to think of this
courses I'm gonna can watch a couple of
videos asynchronously on my own it's not
watching TV
hopefully the stories the episodes the
human beings they're going to challenge
you they're going to evoke you they're
going to stimulate you